You know when the computer starts up,
it has to boot.
Bootstrap is what that means at
bootstraps itself by continuing to
engage in more and more complex
processes as it starts up,
so it starts up with a simple process
and that triggers a more complex process
and that way the computer boots itself
into existence.
Well,
that's exactly what we did,
except we did it over like 3 billion
years,
right?
We started out as these unbelievably
simple organisms that could pretty much
do nothing at all except replicate and
develop much more and more complex forms
over this tremendously long period of
evolutionary history.
Right?
So that's how we solve the problem that
you can't know anything without knowing
something and that you can't have
knowledge without generating it.
It's a little knowledge,
a little more generation,
a little knowledge,
a little more generational little
knowledge.
This huge spiraling cross as an expense
extends over vast amounts of time,
information encoded in your body,
right?
As part of your,
as part of the nature of your being and
information encoded in your culture
reflected inside you and acted out in
the world,
and as scientists,
you know,
with this 500 year history of science
behind us,
we always believed that it's the
material substrate of things.
That's the reality,
but it is more complicated than that
because even the material substrate that
we consider us scientists isn't merely
unformed stuff,
right?
It has structure.
It's patterned,
it's full of information,
and there are physicists working now who
believed that conceptualization of the
ground of being the material grounded of
being as the information is a more
fruitful metaphor than conceptualization
of the ground of being as like unformed
matter.
It's not unformed,
right?
It's pattern and regular informative so
that if you investigated it reveals
order.
That's not just a material structure.
So if you go back to Democritus,
right?
The person who originated the atomic
hypothesis,
democritus actually says two things.
Not One.
He says everything's made out of atoms.
Little bits of stuff,
but the other thing he says is Adam's
array themselves in space array
themselves,
and what that means is that the atomic
structure of things,
his pattern and the pattern is just as
real.
The atoms themselves,
it's the pattern.
That's the knowledge,
right?
A pattern.
That's the information.
So while we encounter as conscious
beings is this complex sleep pattern to
ray,
which we then turned into knowledge,
usable knowledge.
I said,
well,
how would this metaphorical
representation work?
And so the way I want you to look at
this figure is like this.
Imagine this as distant,
right as lurking in the background.
So this is the ground of all being
manifesting itself as one primordial
archetype or one,
one metaphor,
one standard mode of metaphorical
representation.
Why this figure?
While this is complicated,
I think
if you show men picture of a beautiful
woman with her eyes avert while you're
doing a brain scan,
mapping of their nucleus,
accumbent,
nothing happens.
Why is that relevant?
Well,
the nucleus accumbens is part of the
underlying emotional circuitry that
governs approach behavior and pleasure
and approach behavior and pleasure very
tightly intertwined.
If you show the same picture of a
beautiful woman with her eyes locked on
his is nucleus accumbens will light up.
Why is that?
Well,
it's partly because men are innately
attuned to who to female beauty.
Female beauty has a standard form.
It's replicable cross culturally,
it constitutes the average human human
female form,
but more than that,
the gays locking is an indication of
shared attention and it's also the
indication of the initial establishment
of a shared attentional space and it's
an invitation and that invitation
activates approach circuits really even
if it's just a picture.
So when you can see this,
if you walk into any drugstore or any,
any,
any drug store that sells magazines,
what do you see on the men's magazines?
You see an infinite array of beautiful
women and in the female magazines,
the women's magazines,
you see an infinite array of beautiful
women.
Now just exactly why is that?
Well,
there's something absolutely compelling
about female beauty,
and then you have to ask yourself,
what the hell does compelling mean?
Okay,
so what compelling means is you're
busily engaged in a goal directed task
and something happens in your peripheral
vision,
so to speak,
that attracts your attention.
Now that attention is attracted by
processes that are fundamentally
unconscious,
which means processes that occur before
you can think so you can imagine a loose
collection of college age males having a
conversation in a bar when someone
beautiful walks by and one or more of
them capture out of the corner of their
eyes orientation,
right?
Unconscious.
Why?
Because there's something about that
pattern form that grips attentional
systems and direct observation towards
it.
So then you think,
okay,
human beings are really,
really complicated pattern processes and
you think,
well,
partly what we're trying to get a handle
on here is the nature of the world and
partly what we know already is that
there are aspects of the world that you
can't understand always and then you
think,
well,
people are trying to get a grip on the
fact that there are parts of the world
that you can understand so that there's
this transcendent element to being that
always escapes encapsulation.
How would you represent it?
Well,
it's the transcendent element of things
that always attracts your attention
implicitly beyond your control,
so allow noise or a scream or the cry of
a baby or anything horrific,
right?
Blood broken bodies.
These are stimuli that are so
representative of trouble that you can't
help but attend to them,
and then you can imagine that all of the
stimuli,
so to speak,
that you can't help but attend to,
can be a male dominated into
representations of the transcendent
aspect of reality,
and that's what you see in this
representation right here.
So you see a weird intermingling of
female sexuality plus some very distinct
genital symbolism.
Why genital so imagine that that's a
Volvo opening.
Why
before we had any scientific knowledge
at all at school 10,000 years ago,
what the hell is inside a body?
While we knew that,
I guess a little bit from hunting,
right?
We knew the interior of a body.
What is it about the interior of a body
that allows new forms to be generated?
How is it that mothers can give birth to
children?
How is it that one form that's complex
and attractive and mysterious can give
rise to another form?
Why is that useful knowledge from a
representational perspective,
because there's some association between
the Feminine Form,
from a metaphorical perspective and the
capacity for nature to give rise to new
forms
and then you see a representation of a
typical monstrous form that's Kelly,
the Hindu goddess,
the devour and in this representation.
So she's like a more developed version
of tie a mat.
That's a good way of thinking about her.
She's not so much unspeakable anymore.
You could actually say a few things
about Kelly.
You could say,
well,
she's like a spider because she has
eight legs and she weaves a web of fate
and you can say,
well,
her web is made out of fire because if
you get too near to her,
you'll burn up and you could say she
glares at you with eyes that are
unblinking and you could say she has a
tongue like a tiger,
and you could say that she carries
weapons of destruction and it has a head
dress of skulls and that her hair is on
fire.
And you could say that she's giving
birth to this guy as nature gives birth
to human beings and is devouring him at
the same time,
intestines first,
and then you could say,
well,
you could imagine that the first few
people that made a representation like
that shock themselves quite badly.
Right?
Because this is a.
This is a representation of,
of fear itself in a sense,
but not exactly.
It's also a representation of those
stimuli that if you're human are going
to make you both afraid and compelled
just like.
It's hard to look away from fire even if
it's burning something down.
Then you wanted to have around
rats.
If you raise a route to juvenile status
and then washed and cat odor,
it will completely short circuit why?
Well,
the rats never seen a cat.
So exactly what the hell is it
responding to you think,
well,
you can say,
well it's not a conditioned stimulus,
right?
Because the routes never encountered a
cat.
There's something deep in the brain of
that wrap that knows something about cat
odor was never encountered a cat.
So exactly what is it perceiving?
Well,
in some sense,
I think the notion that it's perceiving
is wrong,
it isn't perceiving,
it's just going like this.
That's the representation.
While I'm with chimpanzees who are more
complex,
there are other stimuli that evoke
exactly that kind of response.
Chimps don't like snakes,
dander alive.
Plastic,
rubber doesn't matter.
They don't like snakes.
If you put one in their case,
they get as far away from the snake as
they can as quickly as possible,
and then they look at it because I
suppose if you're a chimpanzee,
even if you don't like snakes,
it's a good idea to know where they are.
Right?
So it's similar to repel,
repelling snake plus attractive.
Yeah.
Well you better look at it and see where
it's going to go.
Chimpanzees don't like unconscious
chimpanzees,
so if you knock a chimpanzee out with
anesthetic and you bring the body of the
chimpanzee back into the chimpanzee
cage,
the chimps do exactly the same thing
away from the body,
but they look at it.
They don't like masks made of chimpanzee
faces while three year old kids don't
like masks either.
There are these underlying perceptual
primitive,
so to speak that likely activate lower
limbic mechanisms in our brains that say
to us,
this is a place suddenly where something
unexpected that you probably do not like
or will not like is very,
very likely to happen.
So you can imagine that an environment
characterized by
unconscious bodies or blood or the
presence of spiders or snakes,
etc.
Might be a place where primates,
such as yourself may encounter things
that they don't know how to cope with.
Therefore afraid.
Right?
SaMe with fear of the dark,
and then you could imagine that the dark
is populated with all of these monsters
of the unknown and you get some notion
of what's happening to children who are
afraid of the dark.
Why are they afraid of the dark?
because in the dark,
which is the place you don't know,
learned things that could hurt a
creature like you.
What things,
how we can't exactly say,
but if you give children exposure to
books and to adult conversation and to
television soon,
those limbic structures that are
populating the darkness with unnameable
fear start to populate it up with
skeletons and vampires and monsters and
so forth and so on,
has the representational structures that
the brain is capable of generating,
say,
well,
fear of inducing things are like that.
They're bloody.
They're dangerous.
They look like serpents.
They look like insects.
They lurk in the dark.
They sneak up on you,
et cetera,
all mangled together into some sort of
monsters form.
Now I want to read you a story.
All right,
so let me give you a little background
to this story.
This story popped into my head in one
chunk like complete,
which I thought was kind of interesting,
but it was also a story that emerged in
solution to a problem I'd been thinking
about for a long time because I was
dealing with this guy who didn't want to
grow up.
So he's caught in a kind of peter pan
situation and peter pan pan means
everything.
Hey,
pan,
like pantheistic and peter pan is a
child who won't grow up.
Now he's magical.
Well,
okay,
fine.
Children live in a magical world,
right?
They're rife with possibility.
He's magical.
He doesn't want to grow up,
so he lives in neverland with the lost
boys.
Neverland doesn't really exist in the
lost boys are obviously boys who haven't
managed to establish some mode of being
and he's in constant battle with captain
hook and captain hook's a tyrant,
right?
A pirate,
a negative manifestation of the negative
archetype of social order.
And captain hook is always fighting
peter pan because peter pan represents
childhood and vulnerability and he
doesn't want to be vulnerable,
so they're locked in this sort of
eternal bout and lots of people I think
more commonly men but not necessarily
get caught in this peter pan problem.
So I was dealing wiTh
person who was caught in this situation,
didn't want to grow up,
wouldn't sacrifice childhood.
And so this story popped into my head.
It's called cock-a-doodle-doo.
Once upon a time there was a man who had
a long hard journey ahead of him.
He was trudging along the way over
boulders and through brushes when he saw
a little shiny him with big white teeth
and the black toupee sitting by the side
of the road,
he was drumming on a log with two white
bones and humming oddly to himself.
The little gnome said,
john,
why woRk so hard?
Why I walked so fast?
Who knows if you'll ever get there?
Anyway,
come over here.
I have something to show you.
So john walked off the road.
He was sick of walking anyway because
people kept throwing sticks and stones.
Adam little gnome said,
I have a shiny red jewel that I would
like to sell you cheap.
Here it is.
And for beneath his cloak,
he pulled the biggest ruby that the man
had ever seen.
It must've weighed 100 pounds and it
shown like the sun.
The gnome said,
do you like it?
It'S an enchanted stone.
What will you offer me for it?
And the man said,
I don't have much,
much money,
but I'll give you everything.
I have the known look displeased.
So john added,
I could pay some more monthly.
So the gnome excepted,
fair enough,
buy now,
pay later.
Sounds good for me.
I'm all for the installment plan.
So the man gave the gnome all his money
and promise to pay the rest later,
and the gnome walk back into the bush by
the road,
clacking his teeth and giggling and
twitching.
The more the man thought about this ruby
and the great deal he got,
the happier he became.
He started back on the road with a light
heart,
but soon discovered that he couldn't
make much progress because 100 pounds
was a lot to carry.
He said to himself,
why continue?
anyways?
I have what I want.
I'll just stand here holding my ruby.
And when people walk by,
they can see how well I've already done.
So he stopped a little while.
One of his little while later,
one of his friends came along,
so I'm standing there.
His friends said,
john,
why don't you come along with me?
I've just opened a new business and I
could really use some help.
Come along quick.
it will be opening soon and thought that
sounded good.
But his friend was in a hurry.
He said he couldn't.
He see the ruby.
How could he speed along beside him?
Where would he put his jewel?
So he said,
thanks,
but I have to take care of my jewel.
Maybe I'll see you later.
His friend looked at him like he was
crazy,
but he was trying to get somewhere
quick,
so he just shrugged a bit and said,
okay,
john,
see you later.
And he sped on down the road.
A little while later,
another friend came by and he said,
john,
nice to see you.
I'm going back to school.
There are lots of wonderful things to
learn.
Great things to do.
The world is full of unsolved problems.
I could use some company.
What would you like to come along?
John thought that sounded pretty good,
but this friend who looked like he was
in a hurry,
he started standing beside the road,
holding the jewel was tiring and he
needed all the energy you had for that.
So he said to his friend,
thanks,
but I have to take care of my jewel.
Isn't it beautiful?
Maybe I'll see you later.
His friend looked at him like he was
crazy,
but he was trying to get somewhere
quick,
so he just shrugged and said,
hope.
Everything goes all right with you.
See you later.
Many friends came and went.
In the years,
went by,
the jewel got heavier and heavier,
but the man got more and more attached
to it.
The only thing was nobody seemed to
notice how beautiful it was.
People would rush by and talk about
their plans and nobody had a ruby as big
and nobody seemed likely to get a ruby
is big and you think that someone
might've had said something like at
least nice ruby john,
sure wish I had one like that,
but it never happened.
Then one day someone new came down the
road.
He was bent over and he was thin and his
hair was gray.
Although he didn't look that old,
he was carrying a big dirty rock
carefully in his arms and he wasn't
making much progress.
The strange figure approached and
glanced up at john.
Then he grinned and said,
where are you standing there so stupidly
with a big ugly rock and you're tired.
Old hands.
You look pretty daft.
I bet you wish you had a big ruby like
the one I am carrying.
And john thought this poor man is
diluted.
He's carrying a rock because you have
the ruby.
So he said,
excuse me sir,
but you are sadly mistaken.
I'm the one with the jewel.
I met a little known by the side of the
road and he sold it to me.
I'm still paying for it,
although not so very much.
You are carrying a rock.
Tired.
Stranger looked annoyed.
He said,
I didn't know what game you're playing,
mr.
You have a rock.
I have a jewel.
The little gnome you described sold it
to me and he said it was the only one.
I've been carrying it for 20 years and
I'll never let it go.
And john said,
but I'd been carrying mine for 20 years
too.
it can be just a rock rocker jewel on
and on.
They argued.
Suddenly I would step the little gnome
as if he'd never left.
Only this time he wasn't so little,
he was bigger and redder and menacing
and his laugh sounded like the rattling
of chains.
Quit arguing youtube.
I've never seen a site quite so
pathetic.
You're carrying rocks,
both of you and if you would have ever
had the sense to put them down for a
second or two,
you would have seen that,
oh well,
at least you were diligent.
I played a mean trick.
I feel bad,
so I'm going to give you What you really
deserve.
Do you want what you really deserve?
and john and the thin stranger nodded,
eagerly.
finally,
they thought you haven't seen anything
yet.
It's wrote down your rocks.
So john and the thin stranger obeyed
each rock,
split down the middle.
When it hit the ground,
outflow the river of ravenous white
worms which rushed towards the men and
devoured them whole while they thrashed
about and screamed.
Soon nothing was left except a leg bone
from each.
The little gnome pick them up and walked
off the road.
He sat down by a hollow log and started
to drum.
He drummed any waited and he hummed and
hawed a little tune
picture of food feeds the whole Hungary
clan,
the image of good mix,
the whole healthy men.
Why walk for miles?
Why do the work?
Just smile.
The smile,
success after all is a quirk.
Life isn't real.
That's the message I give.
It's easy that way.
Plus who wants to live?
So needless to say,
the guy that I was telling this story to
never listened to it and things really
didn't go well for him for a long,
long time and they really didn't go well
for him until he was willing to give up
some of the things he was carrying
along.
So he had acquired,
for example,
a numBer of things that he couldn't
afford and the fact that he was carrying
them right,
paying for them month after month,
man,
he couldn't afford to get an education,
was perfectly willing to sacrifice the
possibility of getting an education for
the image of success rather than the
reverse.
Right?
And he was completely irritated that the
world,
because he had all these trappings of
success,
which no one he admired,
also admired,
and he absolutely wasn't getting
anywhere and he thought that was
tremendously unfair,
but the truth of the matter was that
how'd he put down what he was carrying
for even a moment,
then he would have been able to get to
where he wanted to go.
And that's a motif that succinctly and
dramatically describes the necessity for
sacrifice.
One of the things you see in
psychotherapy very,
very commonly is that the person who's
coming for help does the same damn thing
over and over and over.
And every time they do it,
it has the same consequence bad.
So they ended up with the same kind of.
They ended up in the same kind of
relationship,
right?
It starts out well,
and the person turns against them and
starts to abuse them.
They get abused repeatedly than a dan's.
Then they meet someone else and the
cycle continues.
It doesn't seem to matter who they're
out with,
either they pick a person like this or
they turn the person into someone like
that.
They lose jobs the same way.
Are there educational hopes failed the
same way?
Why?
Well,
the person thinks,
man,
the structure of the world is so unfair.
Everyone else seems to be getting along
just fine,
but me,
I get hit in the head over and over
exactly the same way.
And then you think,
well,
what is the structure of the world?
Exactly.
And then you remember,
well,
you know,
there's the things you don't understand
and there's the things you do understand
and the things you do understand
structure you and protect you,
but you know sometimes the things you do
understand are the right things,
right?
You're valuing something.
You're carrying something that's an
impediment to your further progress and
it's frequently the case that it's the
kind of impediment that under no
conditions do you want to give up
because there's something about you that
says,
like john says about the ruby,
look,
it's a ruby.
Who the hell cares if it weighs 100
pounds and I have to stand by the road,
right?
I still got the ruby and all you'd ever
have to do is put the damn thing down
and wander off and everything would be
just fine,
but you won't do it.
Why?
Because you don't want to give up what
you know because you don't want to
sacrifice anything.
Well,
long before people had any psychological
acumen or any psychological knowledge,
they'd already figured out that if you
are going to take on a figure like this
and expect to get absolutely anywhere
with her right,
the horrors of the world,
you bloody well better be willing to
sacrifice whatever is necessary to keep
you going along your path right?
Unfortunately,
the things that you have to sacrifice
her,
often,
those things that you're most
particularly compelled by our grip,
by or value the things that you want to
give up least,
which is why in archaic societies where
all of this is dramatized,
people's sacrifice,
an animal that they value particularly
or earlier than that even a child that
they value particularly right?
Dramatically portraying the idea of
sacrifice.
You have to give something up if you
Want to make an inroad on what she
represents,
and so then you say,
the purpose of sacrifice is to turn the
terrible aspect of the world into the
benevolent aspect of the world,
and this is diana,
not a hindu goddess of a greek or roman
goddess.
Same
idea applies in the hindu case.
If you make the appropriate sacrifices,
then the terrible aspect of the world
turns into the benevolent aspect of the
world and it is the case that even
empirical studies of success indicate
that intelligence is a handy thing to
have,
but hard work and dedication is a handy
thing to have to.
And what that means is that you're
constantly willing to sacrifice the
impulsive pleasure of the president for
the hopes of payback in the future.
For example,
you sacrifice immediate gratification to
obtain an appropriate social role to
take your place in society.
It's definitely a sacrifice,
right?
Because you put off pleasures in the
moment to obtain longterm stability in
productivity
to turn the world into this
and so then you can say,
this is how the world falls apart.
As it's explored,
right,
so first of all,
there's the thing that you can't even
name that only fills you with dread,
but also with a sense of possibility,
and that manifests itself in your life
as something concrete that you don't
know,
promising and threat,
and that divides itself up into those
aspects of the world that you value in
and admire and that whole promise for
you and those aspects of the world that
don't.
And that's a differentiation,
a consequence of exploration.
It's not a differentiation of world into
objects though.
It's a differentiation of the world into
categories of emotion that was things
that are good for you.
Those things that are bad for you and
the source that they're derived from,
right?
That's the background of the world will
stop.
No.